[Musica]
come scegliete una birra quando andate a
cosa scegliere una birra come la
sceglietela scegliete in base al gusto
immagino al colore può essere bionda
comprata scura alla provenienza italiana
tedesca inglese magari al prezzo al
contenuto alcolico qualcuno forse la
sceglierà perché e biologica ma quanti
di voi hanno mai scelto una birra perché
prodotta con energie rinnovabile quanti
hanno mai pensato di aprire un conto
corrente perché la banca utilizza
energia rinnovabile o comprare un
telefono perché l'azienda che glielo
propone utilizza il 100 per cento
energie rinnovabili all'interno del
proprio ciclo produttivo
questo è il tema di cui parlerò oggi di
quella che si chiama transizione
energetica verso un mondo alimentato al
100 per cento di energie rinnovabili e
nel quale il consumatore abbiamo un
ruolo molto importante perché possiamo
accelerare e di molto questa transizione
perché sono importanti le energie
rinnovabili perché risolvono quello che
è considerato un paradigma energetico
cioè noi abbiamo da una parte la
popolazione mondiale che cresce
continua a crescere dei livelli
incredibile
passeremo da sette più miliardi a 8 più
miliardi nel giro di dieci anni
due terzi di queste persone al 2050
vivranno in città che ti chiedono tanta
energia elettrica è sempre di più la
tecnologia ci porta ad utilizzare
l'energia elettrica pensate alla grande
e digitalizzazione a tutti data center
che consumano tanta energia e più ci
sono fenomeni di elettrificazione dei
consumi utilizzo di mezzi come per
esempio le auto elettriche che passano
dall utilizzo di combustibili fossili
all'elettricità oppure anche il
riscaldamento delle case che fino a poco
tempo fa era praticamente impensabile
immaginarsi che si potesse fare
l'elettricità tutto questo quindi
richiede una grandissima quantità di
energia elettrica ed è un paradosso
perché d'altra parte noi abbiamo la
necessità di fare che cosa di ridurre il
quantitativo di emissioni di co2 immessa
in atmosfera
il fenomeno dei cambiamenti climatici un
fenomeno che non è più solo un fenomeno
studiato da scienziati è qualcosa che è
sotto gli occhi di tutti anche grazie a
degli splendidi lavori fatte da
fotografi come ventura che ci fa vedere
come si stanno ritirando ghiacciai ed è
diventato anche un fenomeno
di massa dal punto di vista della
conoscenza fra i futures di questi
ultimi mesi ci hanno ci hanno fatto
vedere quanto interessa questo argomento
e quanto il mondo inizia a capire quanto
sia importante lo stesso l'attenzione
sulla climate week che c'è stata a new
york poche poche settimane fa
in questo senso l'energia rinnovabile
aiutano a fare questo disaccoppiamento
cioè a produrre più energia e a ridurre
il quantitativo di emissioni emesse in
atmosfera ed è quello che sta succedendo
la crescita dell'energia rinnovabile gli
ultimi dieci anni è stata impressionante
sono cresciuti ad un ritmo molto
superiore a quello che si pensava i
target quello che si pensava sarebbe
stato diciamola la produzione di energie
rinnovabili al 2030 in realtà è stata
raggiunta 12 anni prima è stata
raggiunta nel 2018 con praticamente in
quasi tutti i paesi del mondo
questo perché è guidato da
essenzialmente due macro trend macro
fenomeni il primo è la maturità
tecnologica energie rinnovabili se
guardiamo per esempio il wind sono
cresciute tantissimo sono cresciuto e
proprio anche d'italia come crescono
diciamo ragazze hanno raggiunto delle
taglie che fino a pochi anni fa erano
erano incredibilmente impensabile
guardate questo questo grafico cosa
rappresenta
e lo stesso è successo per esempio a che
sul solare sul fotovoltaico
i pannelli per esempio sono diventati
bifacciali riescono a cogliere l'energia
che arriva diretta dal sole trasforma
l'energia elettrica ma anche quella che
viene riflessa dal suolo e prenderla
quindi anche dalla parte opposta e
questo tipo di tecnologia mi piace
ricordare che è stata sviluppata anche
qui a catania in una fabbrica che sta
proprio qua vicino e che rappresenta una
delle eccellenze mondiale in questo tipo
di tecnologia ha fatto sì che comunque
ha contribuito e contribuirà sempre di
più a ad utilizzare rinnovabili come
elemento per produrre produrre l'energia
elettrica l'altro fenomeno è quello del
costo negli ultimi dieci anni un
pannello solare sia ridotto il suo
prezzo dell 85 per cento
la metà il costo di una turbina eolica
perché è una conseguenza è qui entriamo
nella parte forse più importante è che
visto che sto per raccontare una
conseguenza di quello che erano gli
incentivi sistema di incentivi che
ma ci sono sviluppati dieci anni fa
circa dieci anni fa un po poco di più in
europa sono le grandi incentivi che sono
stati diciamo stabilite da un po tanti
stati in europa ha fatto sì che ci sia
stato un volume di investimenti nel
mondo tale su queste energie che oggi è
il solare fotovoltaico hanno raggiunto
una maturità tecnologica e delle
economie di scala tali per cui oggi
rinnovabili non hanno più bisogno di
incentivi sono competitive competono con
il carbone in molti mercati conviene già
oggi se costruire un impianto solare in
sync è un impianto a carbone in alcuni
sono ancora poche ma saranno sempre di
più conviene spegnere le centrali a
carbone e costruire centrali solari
impianti solari o foto e questo ha fatto
fa si che ormai il costo dell'energia
rinnovabile non sia più una barriera di
costo per il consumatore finale
qualunque prodotto ad oggi fatto che
energie rinnovabili costa esattamente
uguale o meno a quello fatto con
utilizzando energia e diciamo da fonti
fossili e questo fenomeno hanno
intercettato anche tante corporation
tante società compagnie americane e non
solo campagna mondiale sono
multinazionali che hanno deciso di
definire dei target di decarbonizzazione
ha deciso di andare cento per cento
clienti questi sono solo i numeri di
un'iniziativa che si chiama agli one
hundred recente nel quale questa società
si sono impegnate a trasformare il loro
proprio ad utilizzare il sole energie
rinnovabili e andranno ad influenzare
ancora di più il futuro le previsioni
che vediamo sono di crescita continua
oggi rappresentano il 26 per cento dei
consumi mondiali di energia arriveranno
a più del 40 nel 2030 e ha più del 65
nella nel 2050 e credo che siano numeri
che sono soste stimati come lo erano
sottostimati quelle del 2008 perché il
fenomeno sarà e sarà ancora ancora molto
più forte e lo sarà anche perché le
energie rinnovabili oltre ad avere
diciamo ormai raggiunto l'economicità ed
essere compatibili con l'ambiente in
perché non emettono co2 hanno anche
delle degli altri grande caratteristiche
che serviranno ai paesi in via di
sviluppo per soddisfare la loro crescita
di quel miliardo di persone che
che aumenteranno diciamo nei prossimi
dieci anni la stragrande maggioranza
sarà nei paesi in via di sviluppo e le
rinnovabili che cosa hanno hanno la
capacità di rispondere oggi alla loro
esigenza di crescita impianti del genere
possono essere costruiti in un anno
contro i 56 anni di un impianto a
carbone o i dieci anni di un impianto
nucleare e quindi hanno la capacità di
rispondere immediatamente le esigenze
della crescita danno lavoro da un lavoro
spesso qualificato riducono la
dipendenza energetica del paese sono
scalabili vuol dire che riescono a
rispondere ad esigenze delle grandi
citta che crescono e quindi a produrre
energia in grandi quantità ma anche a
rispondere alle esigenze della
elettrificazione rurale in quei posti
dove questa è una foto africana ma ci
sono tanti posti in asia sud america
dove l'elettricità non c'è se ci si
viene prodotta da generatori diesel che
sono sporchi e rumorosi e anche molto
costose in più anche laddove la rete
arriva nei paesi in via di sviluppo
danno un contributo incredibile la
stabilizzazione della rete ci sono
questo e un esempio di un ospedale in
africa che pur essendo connesso alla
rete elettrica quindi avendo elettricità
si trovava fino a poco tempo fa in
condizioni critiche perché ragionano
frequenti blackout l'incubo in cui
parlato mi raccontava che lui un certo
punto era costretta ad operare con la
pila in bocca perché li manda via la
corrente si trova in situazione davvero
drammatica e quindi con rischio per la
vita del paziente e sistemi del genere
che sono semplici come i pannelli
fotografici c'è una batteria hanno
risolto il problema e notte riusciranno
anche a risolverlo aiuteranno a
risolvere quello che il problema della
crescita
esiste un nesso fortissimo tra l'energia
l'acqua e il cibo
tutti e tre sono fortemente connesse
quindi provate a immaginare cosa vuol
dire produrre a fare agricoltura senza
acqua o cosa vuol dire fare agricoltura
senza avere l'energia per raffreddare i
cibi e quindi garantire una catena del
freddo che lo porta a galla diciamo la
distribuzione significa buttare via
tanto cibo ma le energie ma non è solo
un tema di paesi in via di sviluppo a
braccetto delle leggi e delle
rinnovabili ci dà tanta innovazione e
innovazione saranno dei fattori
abilitanti per migliorare questo
percorso per esempio l'automazione
all'automazione dicevamo nei nei
processi di controllo l'utilizzo dei
droni i pannelli solari sono diciamo un
po come quei ragazzi che a scuola
stanno in classe se ce n'è uno che fa
rumore che non ti disturba nessuno
studia e lo stesso succede con i
pannelli se uno si guasta si tira dietro
un'inefficienza sono tantissime anche
pannelli che sono collegate
l'utilizzo di un drone di una thermocar
inga di una termocamera
dell'intelligenza artificiale consentono
consentiranno sempre più di rendere
queste tecnologie è molto più efficienti
verranno combinate tra di loro e vengono
già contaminate tra di loro
questo è un impianto negli stati uniti
in cui si è stato combinato un solare
con un impianto geotermico sembra
assurdo un impianto così è molto più
efficiente utilizzabile il suolo
utilizza meglio le risorse ed è molto
più come dire utile per per produrre
grandi quantità di energia
la realtà aumentata
allora o realtà virtuale sono delle
degli altri strumenti che aiuteranno
nella transizione energetica perché
aiuteranno la formazione di quelle
persone che al momento sono occupate in
diciamo nel settore dei combustibili
fossili e dovranno essere riformate per
andare a lavorare
diciamo in contesti completamente
diverse quindi in contesti nei quali la
tecnologia è molto diversa in questo
tipo di tecnologie aiutano aiutano tanto
a portare tutti quanti non lasciare
nessuno indietro ea lavorare nel nuovo
contesto e serviranno anche dei fattori
abilitanti dei fattori abilitanti
importanti ho detto prima che le energie
rinnovabili garantiscono una maggiore
indipendenza energetica del paese
non dobbiamo più comprare petrolio
carbone da altre paese però dipenderemo
da chi costa dal tempo le previsioni del
tempo saranno fondamentali
una vita dei caratteri 6
dell'elettricità e che non si può
normalmente in condizioni facili
accumulare nel senso che tutto quello
che viene prodotta e messa in rete deve
essere consumata immediatamente ogni
secondo quindi sapere quanto si produce
avere delle forti previsioni del tempo
in questo caso del vento della risorsa
vento della risorsa solare saranno
fondamentali per riuscire a dire a
predire
quella quantità che si mette rete quindi
a gestire la rete serviranno tanti
investimenti nelle reti e soprattutto
serviranno tante batterie
le batterie sono per ora la forma se
vogliamo parte l'idroelettrico in
generale una delle forme migliori per il
per l'accumulo di energia sono batteria
come quelle che tutti voi avete nei
cellulari oggi spenti come diceva prima
emanuele sono semplicemente impilati uno
sopra l'altro e producono hanno la
capacità di garantire che cosa di
garantire che la domanda di energia
segue un pò l'offerta cioè di fare in
modo che quando magari energia viene
prodotta di giorno e non viene consumata
possa essere trasferita la notte è
sempre di più la tecnologia servirà a
fare in modo che magari l'energia
prodotta questa settimana possa essere
prodotta e utilizzata tra un'altra
settimana o da un'asta addirittura da
una stagione all'altra perché d'estate
magari c'è più irraggiamento e d'inverno
ce n'è di meno tutto questo diciamo
quello che farà l'innovazione richiederà
aiuterà tantissimo allo sviluppo di
posti di lavoro molto qualificati in
tantissimi settori che non sono
necessariamente quelli delle delle
tecnologie ci sarà molto digitale ma
tutto ciò che sa fare l'innovazione non
è niente di quello che non c'è già
adesso perché quello che già adesso che
oggi in energie rinnovabili come dicevo
prima sono già competitive
esistono sono molto efficienti ed hanno
la possibilità a chiunque di noi di fare
delle scelte per contribuire ad
accelerare questa transizione energetica
aiutare a portarci a spostarci da fonti
di energia che emettono co2 a fonti che
non le mettono
e lo possiamo fare con gesti semplici
per cui magari la prossima volta che
andate a bere una birra se la scegliete
rinnovabile avete fatto un favore a chi
ma grazie
[Musica]